Evan started giving speeches I just
wanna YMCA only three people showed up
with those three led to more the amount
of motivation inspiration and valuable
insight I've got from Evan Carmichael's
channel is crazy
but most of all thank you for helping me
believe thank you for helping me to
understand the power of having one word
and what a difference it can make
thank you for all your inspiring videos
and articles I'm so grateful for the
opportunity to be the part of the team
it's so awesome to know that work that
you do is needed and helps other people
thank you for inspiring me to take that
leap of faith for moving from Chicago
out to California to pursue my dreams as
an actor has me feeling empowering
through tough times I want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart
you've helped make my life so much more
fulfilling first of all thank you so
much for showing me new ways of starting
a business new ways of selling thank you
so much for helping me find my one word
love
god I love it everyone has helped me a
lot by reminding me that success is a
protocol perseverance and thank you so
much for everything that you do I share
you know one word with all of my clients
thank you for showing us an importance
of living the copper gold and thank you
for being real man Evan thank you so
much for giving me a platform to help me
find out who I'm truly supposed to be
Evan believes in you when she backs it
up with his action and that is one of
the most amazing things your advice and
how to get to focus really means to
lesson yeah be really patient
thanks for the motivation the
inspiration to follow our dreams I want
to say thank you for really helping me
getting outside my comfort zone be in
front of the camera you gave me the
opportunity to do what I want and it's
you that made me shine and most of all
thank you for helping me believe
hey hey don't date happy birthday from
the swamp I'm happy birthday happy
birthday dear and then happy birthday
Evan birthday even good day of it happy
birthday brother
happy birthday happy birthday man
wishing you a happy birthday happy
birthday ever
wanted to wish you a very happy birthday
I'm already married happy birthday happy
birthday Evans currently helped over 20
million entrepreneurs but there's still
a long way to go
his dream is to help 1 billion and you
can play a part
imagine all the dreams never realized
imagine all the goal never achieve
imagine other people this close to
making them like gave up because they
didn't indeed make a difference
introduce someone to Evans channel today
I haven't I used to be homeless living
off cans of garbanzo beans till I found
your videos now I live with my mom thank
you for helping me believe she'd do a
little bad with that bye